you know it's been nearly four years
since his near-fatal drug overdose at a
Nevada brothel and it was a turbulent
time for Lamar
there was the rise and fall of his
marriage to Khloe Kardashian the end of
his basketball career and he chronicles
it all in his new memoir darkness to
light we sat down for a revealing it
very candid conversation and trust me
when I tell you Lamar held nothing back
let's talk about this book all right you
put stuff out there petraju Vegas the
hospital when you got there they didn't
think you were gonna make it
yeah I wasn't gonna did you realize you
were goner when you were sitting at that
ranch nah it was just another day of you
know I'm saying being freaky I guess or
trying to be freaky Lamar was partying
at a Nevada brothel for four days when
he was found unresponsive on October 13
2015 was rushed to the hospital on the
brink of death his heart stopped twice
and he suffered 12 seizures and six
strokes cocaine was found in his system
with Lamar alleges the lake brothel
owner Dennis HOF drugged him I didn't
say drugs their name you didn't tell
them it was something in my system
cocaine whatever my system don't know
how they got it in there
but that's my flaw God's honest truth in
your career how much money do you think
you blew through yourself drugs I would
say probably a hundred man when Lamar
suffered the overdose he was in the
midst of a divorce with now ex-wife
Khloe Kardashian she dropped everything
including their divorce petition so she
could take over his medical care
against all odds Lamar recovered what
does Chloe still mean to you today a lot
yeah I still got a lot of love but there
were other woman yeah you said in the
book that you had sex with more than
2,000 women I never really kept a count
I might over exaggerate a little bit
okay was it always safe sex no no do you
worry about that ever of course you know
I've seen what happen our we all know
how real that is how much you think you
hurt her I mean a lot yeah you know a
lot I'm blessed
just for evenness to pick up my phone
call have you guys kind of made amends
now I mean I wouldn't call it amends
I've spoke spoken so recently if you
call that amends if you could say one
thing to Chloe right now what would you
say I love you and thank you for being
there for me when I can't walk or talk
that love will never go away all right
let's move from his love for Chloe to a
little bit of shade I have known Lamar
since before he came into the league and
I found it interesting that I was also
named check in the book so I had to talk
to Lamar and get some things straight
about that I'll read a quote for you
look all right Kevin Frazier from
Entertainment Tonight tried to win
family members over with free fried
chicken in hopes of getting and
exclusive explain that to me I'm going
to explain that
as in your book is in your book is the
bottom doctor wasn't over saying okay I
mean that will have to be offensive to
what I and I'm sorry for that
so I guess my writer muscles just trying
to be creative
whereas right uh I'm sorry if I offended
you bro listen Lamar and I've always
been good and he's one of my favorite
people out there but please just all the
pics Neil but Colonel Sanders
[Applause]
[Music]